Well,
now I'm going to tell you this story.
It's written for four year old kids,
but I want you to take a look at it for
a moment,
from a different perspective and see if
you can imagine exactly what it is that
it's saying.
There's no such thing as a dragon.
Well,
we all know that,
right?
A dragon is a fictitious creature,
reptilian,
terrible lives forever,
breathes fire hordes,
gold,
strange combination of attributes.
Why would something terrible and
ancient?
Hold a treasure.
Billy [inaudible] was rather surprised
when he woke up one morning and found a
dragon in his room.
It was a small dragon about the size of
a kitten.
The dragon wagged it's tail happily.
When billy patted his head.
It's interesting,
you know,
in Chinese mythology,
dragon is a positive figure in European
mythology.
The dragon is something to face in
combat and destroy or something to face
in combat and build something out of the
pieces leftover from the Dragon.
Billy went downstairs to tell his mother
no such thing as a dragon said,
billy's mother,
and she said it like she meant it.
Remember once my daughter had a
nightmare.
She was about four,
this was at the time when she first
started to notice graffiti and litter
and both graffiti and let her bothered
her.
She couldn't understand the motivations
behind the graffiti artists and she
didn't like the fact that there was
litter cluttering up the world's order
and the reason she got sensitive to that
as a child was because children are
really,
really dependent on order.
Right.
I mean,
and the reason for that is that their
realm of competence is rather
restricted.
So they'd like to see things.
Mac messed up.
So little kids for example,
they're not happy with you if you play a
game with them and then mess around with
the rules of the game.
They don't like that at all.
They think that that's immoral activity
to shake up the structure of the game.
Well anyways,
while she was pondering all this,
she uh,
came into our bedroom one night and
said,
Dad,
I had a nightmare.
Now we all know,
right?
Nightmares aren't real.
Just like dragons,
dreams aren't real.
Of course.
Which raises the question of why in the
world you'd bother having them six or
seven hours a night every single day of
your life and why they're a recognized
feature of animal behavior all the way
down to the amphibian level.
She said,
I dreamt that there was a clear flowing
stream,
but in this dream there was all sorts of
garbage and it scared me and bothered me
so much.
I woke up,
so I told her,
look,
close your eyes and imagine the stream.
It's full of garbage.
What should you do about it?
She said,
well,
I should take the garbage out to the
street.
And I said,
all right,
so picture this stream.
Picture yourself cleaning the garbage
out of it.
She calmed down and went back to sleep.
Why?
Well,
because dreams concentrate on threat.
We know that they present threats to
you,
threats you haven't been able to deal
with.
Well,
there's a part of your brain that tracks
threats and it's not really all that
smart.
In some ways.
All it does is say,
look,
here's the problem and it's waiting for
the rest of your brain to conjure up
some solution to that problem and if it
doesn't conjure up a solution and it
just presents the problem over and over
and over and over and over,
so people who have posttraumatic stress
disorder,
for example,
who've been really upset by their
contact with something unexpected,
dream about the same tragedy forever
until they solve it and they solve it by
facing it and living it over and over
voluntarily,
so you might think right off the bat
from listening to that little story that
suggesting to your four year old
daughter who's just had a nightmare that
her fears aren't real and that the dream
representation of them isn't real
because it's not tangible like a table
might not really be the best approach to
the problem.
So you see billy,
he's pretty much got it right,
right off the bat,
right?
The dragon wagged his tail happily.
When billy padded it's head,
Bailey went downstairs to tell his
mother,
there's no such thing as a dragon said,
billy's mother,
and she said it like she meant it,
so there's a dragon in this house.
Now the next thing you might wonder is
how often have you actually gone into a
house where there's a dragon?
My guess is if you don't take this
particularly specifically and allow
yourself to use your imagination and to
think metaphorically for a moment,
you've all encountered dozens of houses
that were filled right to the rafters
with various dragons,
all of which were being studiously
ignored by the people who inhabited the
house.
Billy went back to his room and began to
dress the dragon,
came close to billy in a friendly manner
and wagged his tail,
but billy didn't pat it.
If there is no such thing as something,
it's silly to patted on the head.
Merely washed his face and hands and
went down to breakfast.
The dragon went along.
It was bigger.
Now,
almost the size of a dog.
Billy sat down at the table.
The dragon sat down on the table.
This sort of thing was not usually
permitted,
but there wasn't much billy's mother
could do about it.
She'd already said there was no such
thing as a dragon head.
If there's no such thing,
you can't tell it to get down off the
table.
Sometimes I sit with friends of mine who
had very young children to eat,
say,
and the children,
two or three years old,
don't sit at the table.
They sit on the table or they run around
the table or they run around the table
and pull things off the table,
or they run around the house and pull
things off all the shelves in the house
and keep their parents so busy chasing
them around that they have no time
whatsoever to interact as adults.
Well,
you have to wonder under those
circumstances whether you're dealing
with a child or a dragon,
so to speak,
and you also might wonder whether or not
the dragon is large and unruly,
precisely because the parents are
completely unwilling to admit that it
actually exists.
Mother made some pancakes for billy,
what the dragon ate them all.
Mother made some more,
but to dragon eight,
those two mother kept making pancakes
until she ran out of batter.
Billy only got one of them,
but he said that's all he really wanted.
Anyway,
one time,
ah,
an acquaintance of ours in Boston
brought their son over to be Babysat at
our house and his nanny had just been in
a car accident.
So he was being shunted from house to
house.
Well,
his parents went off to work and uh,
he didn't have very good reputation.
This kid,
he was about four and a,
he came over to our house and with his
mother in the morning and she dropped
them off and she said,
well,
he probably won't eat all day,
but that's all right.
And I thought,
no,
he's four.
If he doesn't eat all day,
that's not all right.
Right.
Because kids,
if they don't eat their basically
horrible,
right?
They don't sleep,
they don't eat,
they're horrible.
So it isn't all right that he doesn't
eat.
So then you think,
well,
maybe there's some sort of dragon
associated with this child that happens
to be interviewing perhaps with his
ability to eat.
So I came back at noon,
my wife had taken care of the children
that day and I walked in the house and
the other four or five kids that we had
in house or off playing in this little
kid was standing in the corner,
like really isolated and looking,
you know,
upset fundamentally.
So I went over and I poked him a bunch
because generally if you poke a kid a
little bit,
you know,
they'll go like this,
the sort of back off,
but sooner or later you can crack them
and they'll smile and then they'll play.
Not this kid,
boy,
there's no bloody way who's going to
play with me.
And that was that like he'd already
learned that adults should either be
ignored or that they were trouble and he
wasn't going to let any adults into his
little world.
So there is absolutely a dragon
associated with that little boy.
And it was eating all his pancakes.
The only went upstairs to brush his
teeth.
Mothers started clearing the table.
The dragon who was quite as big as
mother by this time,
made himself comfortable in the whole
rug and went to sleep.
I really liked this one.
By the time billy came back downstairs,
the dragon had grown so much.
He filled the hall.
Then we had to go around by way of the
living room to get to where his mother
was.
I didn't know.
Dragons grew so fast.
Said Billy,
there's no such thing as a dragon.
Said mother firmly
winning the downstairs.
Took mother all morning what?
With the dragon in the way and having to
climb in and out of windows to get from
room to room.
So you know,
you think back in your own experience
when you've gone to a house where
there's a dragon hiding underneath the
living room rug and nobody's saying
anything about it and then you think,
how long does it take to get something
absolutely simple.
Done in a house that's absolutely jammed
to the rafters with unfinished business
forever,
right?
Organizing people in a household like
that to even do something as simple as
go out for breakfast in the morning or
even perhaps to make a meal is virtually
impossible.
Why?
Well,
because there's something going on in
the household that has been studiously
ignored for a very long time and has
grown so large as a consequence that it
occupies the whole domain.
By noon,
the dragon filled the house,
its head hung out the front door,
it's tail hung out the back door,
and there wasn't a room in the house
that didn't have some part of the dragon
in it.
When the dragon awoke from his nap,
he was hungry.
The bakery truck went by.
The smell of fresh bread was more than
the dragon could resist.
He ran down the street after the bakery
truck.
The house went along,
of course like the shell on a snail.
The mailman was just coming up the path
with some mail for the big speeds.
When their house rush past him and
headed down the street,
he chased the big speed house for a few
blocks,
but he but he couldn't catch it.
When Mr Bixby came home for lunch,
the first thing he noticed was that his
house was gone.
Luckily one of the neighbors was able to
tell them which way it went.
You know,
that sort of thing happens to people not
infrequently to write,
hey,
they're not really looking around much
at what's going on and they come home
from work one day and their house is
gone and what does that mean?
Well,
maybe their children have become
completely alienated from them or maybe
their wife has decided suddenly,
but of course not.
So suddenly to leave.
Why?
Well,
according to this story,
it's because something ignored was
growing in the house.
Mr [inaudible] got in his car and went
looking for the house.
He studied all the houses as he drove
along.
Finally he saw one that looked familiar.
Billy and Mrs.
Bixby,
we're waving from an upstairs window,
you know,
in in the eighties and nineties in India
when our house was being built,
the local priest equivalent to the
priest would come by to set the
foundation stone and when he set the
foundation stone,
he take a big spike and drove it into
the ground and the reason he drove it
into the ground at the place where the
foundation was going to be laid was to
keep the great dragon that is underneath
the earth,
firmly pinned down by its head so it
couldn't move and shake the house to
bits.
And what does that mean?
Well,
it means the same thing that's meant in
the new testament when you're told not
to build your house on a foundation of
sand,
right?
It doesn't matter how good the house is
or how well constructed it is or how
rich it is.
If the foundation is made out of sand or
if it rests on top of a dragon,
there's nothing in that household that's
ever going to be accomplished.
That's positive and the wealth,
the display that the house might consist
of is nothing but a sham.
Mr [inaudible] climbed over the dragon's
head onto the porch roof and through the
upstairs window.
How did this happen?
Mr Bixby asked.
It was the dragon said,
billy,
there's no such thing.
Mother started to say,
there is a dragon.
Billy insisted a very big dragon,
and billy padded the dragon on the head.
The dragon wagged his tail happily.
Then even faster than it had grown.
The dragons started getting smaller
soon.
It was kitten sized.
Yeah,
I don't mind dragons this side said,
mother,
why did it have to grow so big?
I'm not sure he said billy,
but I think it just want it to be
noticed.